two people are 16 kilometers apart on a
straight road to people I'm going to be
very original and call them a and B this
16 kilometers apart on a straight road
they start walking at the same time if
they walk towards each other they'll
meet in two hours okay let's just stop
for a second to people 16 kilometers
apart and they start to walk two on each
other now before I put some areas on to
indicate their direction of movement I'm
just going to assume because of the part
of the question I'm about to read whoops
I just lost the page that they are not
walking at the same speed one is walking
faster than the other that'll become
clear in the next part but just while
I'm drawing it okay if then we're
walking at the same speed they would
obviously be right in the middle right
but one's walking faster so I'm just
going to say a for the sake of argument
is walking faster so you'll cover or
she'll cover more ground than be okay
but they're meeting somewhere on that
original 16 kilometer to them okay they
start walking at the same time they walk
towards each other they'll meet in two
hours two hours to me okay scenario one
but if they walk in the same direction
so the distance between them is
decreasing so that's where I know that
they're walking once walking faster than
the other because they're they're
walking the same direction and they are
not work at different speeds they'll
just stay 16 comments huh there will
meet in eight hours okay so I have a
completely different scenario with
completely different directions so I'm
going to pop that on a second diagram so
here's my original 16 corners
and I posited that a was walking faster
okay which means that a is going to be
trying to catch be run the other way
around so b is walking this way away
from a ok and a is moving that way and
eventually they're going to meet
somewhere because a is going to catch be
ok and this takes eight hours how fast
are they going all right so how do we
approach this question this is all the
information that we're presented or
perhaps I should say this is how the
information is presented now just like
with the problem with the pipes and so
on there's an issue here with the
distances they give you and the the
information of the way it's presented
which doesn't make it entirely
straightforward apart from let trial and
error to work out like they don't hand
to a silver platter here are the
particular variables you need and here's
the procedure you go through and out
will pop out two dollars now I'm just
going to say there on that ameno two
numbers ok we're after two particular
numbers here ok so there are two things
to solve for and there are two
situations and these two situations are
going to give us generate for us two
equations just like we've seen before
two variables I should take constants
two constants to two equations in that
Tower gonna solve it so let's have to
put a bit of information on here I'm
trying to find speeds right so being
that I'll call one capital a and 1
capital B I'm going to name their speeds
lowercase a and lowercase B right so
that I don't confuse them with each
other and I can attach them in a
sensible way to the right things ok ah
their speeds I assume because they
haven't told us otherwise stay the same
otherwise wouldn't really be able to
solve this question so still got the
same speeds on this diagram
and a and B are what I'm solving for so
I want equations in a and B so let's
have a look at scenario one at the top
here right how can I take this
information and turn it into an equation
any equation that relates a and B
together okay hmm i have i have speeds
right this one trying to solve okay i
have a distance and i have a time this
is kind of like the three corners of our
triangle right if I have speed distance
in time I should be able to create a
relationship between them in that way I
just have to know the right way to
combine it ok so I'm going to start by
saying okay well 1616 is the total
distance traveled by a and B in the
amount of time that we've been given
right so I'm going to try to work out
well how do i express that so I could
say well that's equal to 16 that will
use the information that I've been given
okay one no time they run for two hours
okay so let's just think about a how far
is a travel in two hours he's going to
she's going to revise go travel to a
kilometers think about it again I
default back as a problem of strategy to
if I'm not sure about the algebra or get
a concrete example if for instance a was
going 10 Columbus around right I know
two hours she's going to go 20
kilometers it's just double that amount
because that's how long its ok so a is
going to travel that far to pay right
but of course I need to know how far be
travels as well right which by the same
logic is to be okay so I have one
equation so far that was the easy part
most people get to this point ok because
it's simply the Golden Gun I'll just
simplify that a little bit and here is
my equation 1 okay and I'm anticipating
run again equated to a second now this
next part is trickier I'll admit ok
because you know see how we could see
there's like it's like a boundary on
this thing it's all going to add up to
16 how far did they travel in total on
the face of it i don't know i don't tell
us where where this place is right so I
can't take all its equal to
Thames straightaway off the bat but i do
have enough information here to still
work out what that distance is if I
wanted to it's not the actual question
so I'm not going to but I'm going to use
that idea the same way I used here okay
let's think about this a person a using
the same logic I used before how far
does person a travel in this scenario
travels eight a right because still
traveling at the same rate and it's just
traveling for longer right but what does
that distance look like okay we'll just
for the sake of illustration I'm just
going to draw it like this okay so that
distance starts from that point over on
the left and it has to go all the way
over to wherever beers God not to and
then catches in there okay so this is a
day right so far so good but hold on a
second hey right is further than what
this is going to be which of course is
maybe just like before except this time
this is a bit different I know how much
further a is traveled then be because
it's even on the diagram what's the
difference between the distances they're
tracking its 16 isn't it and you can
because I've drawn it out you can see
the difference right here okay so that's
how far a travels because they're
walking faster and that's how far be
travels and the distance between them is
16 okay so look here I have two things
that are equal to each other right
slightly different way of arranging but
I can say that a a should be equal to a
B+ that 16 extra kilometers that 8a is
travel right that make sense see how I
generated it from this scenario so I had
to draw it to see it some of you were
very clever might be able to put like
sort of see it so on in your mind better
I don't okay so i had to write this out
and draw it out from there i have my
second equation I wanted to do is to
simplify a little bit I guess I bring
the
aight be over there to make it nice and
easy to do by elimination I'll divide
through by the common factor and that's
my equation to write and now elimination
is the most obvious way to go 1 + 2 that
gives me to a no more B's that's equal
to 10 so there's one speed that's the
faster person right and so b is going to
travel three colors per hour because we
know that after two hours you're
spending chopped n this person is going
to travel sticks and bass remote so
clearly the hypotenuse question is not
the equations right the hard part is
going from this and then seeing it to be
able to write the correct operations
right and I certainly wouldn't be no do
it had I not drawn a diagram and put all
the information on there and tried to
present a clear way